[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen salis welt
heute gibt es ein schnelles mittagessen
hilfsteam und zwar habe ich mir gedacht
weil ja viele gemüse nicht mögen bei mir
im team
ich glaube sarah ich schon mutter wissen
so die einzigen thema dasitzen und
karotten und sellerie knabbern und dann
muss man den restlichen team immer so
dass gemüse unter jugend genauso wie
demokratisch und auch den kindern wobei
ella ist ganz gerne gemüse deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht verbinde ich doch mal
gemüse mit waffe und gemüse waffeln mit
leckerem toppings da ist es schön
versteckt und ich glaube wenn ich sage
heute gibt es waffeln dann kommt jeder
gleich runter oder rüber wo auch immer
sie sitzen hier im haus und im gebäude
ja ich mache das ganze jetzt als rote
waffel aber ihr könnt im prinzip auch
alle möglichen gemüsesorten nehmen die
ihr gerne habt und die ihr mögt die ihr
vielleicht auch gerade hat als
resteverwertung haut einfach alles in
den teig rein was euch schmeckt dafür
nämlich zweier 300 gramm mehl und einen
teelöffel backpulver oder nehmt einfach
back mail da braucht man kein backpulver
mehr dazu geben dann habe ich hier meine
gemüse mischung von nämlich ne zwiebel 1
knoblauchzehe
karotten und rote paprika beides jeweils
250 gramm 100 gramm tomaten käse da ist
schön würzig und etwas salz pfeffer und
paprikapulver
ich glaube es wird eine schöne mischung
zuerst werde ich jetzt das gemüse
zerkleinern entweder könnt ihr das jetzt
reiben oder auch ganz fein hacken ich
werde jetzt hier die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehe schälen und dann nehme ich
aber den aufsatz hierbei der kenwood und
reibt dann alles ganz fein dann habe ich
nämlich alles gleichmäßig zerkleinert
ich hab nur bisschen angst dass später
die enttäuschung groß ist wenn ich in
unsere whatsapp gruppe schreibt es gibt
waffeln
ich schreib einfach nur es gibt waffeln
und dann gucke ich weg kommt
[Musik]
schmeißt alles schnell hier oben sind
eher kleinerer und zwar nehme ich den
multi zerkleinerer
ich weiß ihr schreibt mir immer tipps
darunter dem wasser in den mund
toastbrot zunge rausstrecken aber es ist
alles nicht so
videoclips deswegen ich stehe es durch
und das gemüse könnte jetzt einfach so
zerkleinern das ist oben in diesem
aufsatz darein hast
das müssen schon reichen
und dann alles nach ländern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ging schnell
und der rest geht jetzt auch recht
schnell gepackt jetzt alle zutaten in
die schüssel und verrät sie miteinander
also das kann man echt mal ganz schnell
zwischendurch machen wenn es mal so
richtig schnell gehen muss
und die paprika so ein bisschen westrich
aber das macht gar nichts dafür habe ich
ja mal mit dabei
[Musik]
ganz wichtig noch die gewürze und
dann noch den käse und da ist einfach so
zu einer meiner lieblings käsesorten der
nomaden käse da ist nämlich im fass
gereift und dadurch ist es sehr sehr
würzig und hat einfach zu nehmen
eigentlich schon so eine konsistenz wie
geriebener parmesan so ein bisschen aber
nicht ganz trocken
jetzt schaue ich mal wieder tank wird
das kommt jetzt auch ein bisschen drauf
an wie wässrig die paprikaschote waren
also wenn es wirklich zu besser ich
werde gebe ich einfach nochmal mehr dazu
wenn der teig zu fest ist dann kann da
noch flüssigkeit oder gemüse dazugeben
[Musik]
der teig sieht so schön aus guckt euch
die farbe an man könnte ihn tatsächlich
war streikende mit voller einfach die
farbe von einer hatte guckt mal
schön
den stelle ich jetzt mal zur seite denn
eigentlich ist der teig jetzt fertig und
kann sofort ausgebacken werden aber dann
sind die waffeln schon fertig und ich
habe keine toppings also wenn ich jetzt
noch ein zwei top ins machen und wenn
die fertig sind hawleys waffeleisen und
dann warten hatte wacker topping 1 wird
also aus einer zucchini hergestellt ich
habe hier noch bisschen thymian aus dem
garten einmal den ganz normalen thema
zitronenthymian olivenöl salz und
pfeffer und die zucchini könnte jetzt
entweder fein schneiden oder fein hobeln
revidiert kurz
wenn man da oben und
dann einfach in olivenöl scharf anbraten
[Musik]
die zucchini ist jetzt soweit die stelle
kurz vorm herd weg und machen noch einen
joghurt stirbt und zwar nämlich dafür
den sahnejoghurt etwas salz und pfeffer
das ist so die basis
und dann werde ich eine hälfte mit senf
und honig verfeinert und die andere
hälfte wird meerrettich
dann passt es zu den verschiedenen
toppings dazu und ich hab ich jetzt
jeweils einen teelöffel senf und einen
tisch
und einen brief mit meerrettich und
was habe ich jetzt noch ich habe da noch
fürs zweite topping lachs dann nämlich
jetzt räucherlachs und
hier noch eine avocado und die schneide
ich jetzt gleich mal in feine scheiben
und kann jetzt auch gleich das
waffeleisen holen und schon mal
aufhalten denn dann sind wir fertig
heute alles gebacken
und dekoriert
guck mal die avocado nimmt er war in die
hand geht dann ganz vorsichtig mit dem
messer ohne dass sie durchschneidet
ihr könnt auch ein buttermesser nehmen
also ein kleines stumpf ist es geht auch
und dann könnte nämlich mit dem löffel
hier einmal entlang
und habt schöne avocado scheibe
und damit die abgabe jetzt nicht braun
wird gleich zitronen oder limettensaft
darüber geben
fertig dann räume ich jetzt hier alles
abholt waffeleisen den teig und dann
wird gepackt
so habe ich jetzt meinen waffeleisen und
nehmen den aktionären und werde jetzt
erstmal runde waffeln auspacken ich
hoffe die gefallen mir so aber bevor ihr
das macht am besten vorher aber fetten
denn im teig habe ich ja außer käse gar
kein fett mit dabei und bei so ganz
normale mass urteil kam es ja wirklich
immer entweder viel butter oder öl und
dann reicht es eigentlich auch schon
aber hier auf jeden fall hätten ich
mache jetzt mal eine eiskugel voll
mal schauen ob sie mir so gefallen wenn
nicht packe ich doch ganze vierecke
aber ich glaube ich bin die so ganz
schön wie so kleine thaler
wir werden sehen
jetzt ist zu spät
ich denke ich packte jetzt mal so vier
minuten was man übrigens noch
eingefallen ist dieses topping mit
meerrettich das ist es farblich so ein
bisschen ab setzt von dem anderen
topping ihr könnt da gern den avocado
kern nehmen den kann man nämlich auch
mit verzehren und der hat eine ganz
tolle orangene farbe
aufzuschießen die ganze zeit
ihr könnt den avocado kern nämlich auch
reiben und dann eine ganz tolle farbe
und besonderen geschmack einfach so ein
bisschen dazugeben
und der verschärft sich dann ganz schön
orange
[Musik]
ich lass das jetzt mal kurz zu stehen
und in wenigen minuten ist oranges zeige
ich euch gleich nochmal
sind wunderschön
doch dach sorgen sie mit gut und
fünf minuten perfekt das heißt ich mache
jetzt hier kurz alle nacheinander aus
und dann werden sie mit doping dekoriert
und fertig gestellt und dann gucke ich
mal mehr zum problem kommt aus dem team
und für wie viel verwunderung wir sorgen
wenn ich sage es gibt waffeln jetzt kann
ich anrichten und guckt mal jetzt her da
rein so sieht jetzt der avocado kern aus
richtig kohle und der bringt echten
tollen geschmack mit rein dann richtig
die jetzt hier einfach an und ruft
gleich das team zusammen
da mach ich noch drauf und ich finde sie
echt
zum schönes fingerfood von geburtstag
oder für eine party oder einfach so bei
uns ist jeden tag party doch so mache
ich das jetzt fertig auf die schöne
platte und dann gucken wir mal probiert
[Musik]
jetzt sind die waffen fertig und ich
habe ihn die gruppe geschrieben wer
möchte probieren die erste diese
gemeinschaft war lena lena darf probiert
hallo
hier warfen gemacht ja diesmal mit lachs
oder ja
schonmal herzhafte waffen gegessen
[Musik]
max probieren ja bitte
langsamer karton oder zucchini sechs
amok ado wilhelm ok aus deutschland oder
willst du nicht heraus
ich weiß nicht ob ich genug salz drin
habe aber
[Gelächter]
naja wie schmeckt so gemüse war finja
karotte und paprika lecker schmeckt sehr
gut sehr frisch das freut mich und ich
glaub das ist auch ein gericht was man
sehr gut war aber auch kalt essen kann
und man kann es vorbereiten und jetzt so
für uns los büro auch ganz gut
und wenn man doch mal was anderes je
nach der person her bist du bei dir ist
so gern gemüse
aber die männer bei uns hier nicht so
der penny verbänden profis veganer wenn
der kein gemüse essen wird dann werde
das wissen wir aus schlecht aber so
kriegen wir glaube ich echt hier alle
dazu ein bisschen mac gemüse zu essen
also probiert gerne das rezept aus
schreibt mir euer feedback und wenn ihr
andere toppings macht dann schreibt mir
auch gerne eure doping rezepte oder
ideen das rezept geht es wie immer auch
sex - blog de oder in der app da können
sie die rezepte auch kopflos umrechnen
und mehr portionen oder weniger
stationen machen und der zutatenliste in
die einkaufsliste schicken und so weiter
probiert werden aus und viel spaß dabei
bis zum nächsten mal washington
das nehme jetzt mit oder für alle ab
[Musik]